he is the UFC Legend Bellator Legend
Pride Championship Legend we made him
drive all the way down from Long Beach
California it's Quentin Rampage Jackson
on this week's food truck Diaries and
I'm feeding them Burgers let's go
[Music]
Mr Rampage Jackson what up big dog how
you doing we're back at it Doug yeah
back at it sent out that Rampage signal
you show up Doug yeah I had to man fresh
off the plane from Vegas yeah he's just
a businessman now man I just be doing it
just doing the damn thing yeah come on I
ain't fighting that much right now I
might as well do it you know you're not
fighting but did you have uh you want to
fight there was a lot of rumors with the
Shannon Briggs fire it was a lot I think
he was just selling wolf tickets I think
he he was just trying to get his name
back out there or something because I
was I'm serious I really wanted to fight
him but it never happened it never
happened but you'd be you'd entertain a
fight right now uh boxing match for sure
100 anybody in general like I said you
were on my boy Adam 22's pot I heard you
thought what are you talking about Daryl
scooting over here
I owe him an ass woman why that poor kid
I don't even think he's on social media
anymore oh oh man hey look I feel bad
about all that part but come on titties
yeah but in the beginning it was all fun
and stuff until he started getting he
started getting mad at me or something
and now you know to be fear though he's
the one that started he made fun of
something on you and then you were like
what you know titties and then it was
off to the race yeah because you did in
front of a group of 16 other dudes were
like titties and then it was just got
roasted oh yeah it was it was bad but
yeah I remember he did start it you know
I mean I like making fun of people and
joking around it's a funny dude I like
having fun but then yeah he took a
little bit too far now that I'm old I'm
on my way out I wanna I wanna kick
everybody's ass with our old ass weapons
too you think you own one [__] oh my
ass woman because you know some people
send me some clips he wrote up on me oh
really yeah and I'm sure he wrote about
me but I didn't do nothing because uh to
be honest I almost almost fought Rashad
on the show too but but I was already in
trouble for that kind of case before
that and I knew he was watching me so
yeah yeah so I was like to keep it cool
yeah so you got Shannon breaks that's
not happening schoonover we don't know
he said he saved me six months
man I need six months and who anybody
else
I have nobody else on my radar uh you
know what I owe um I owe um Marvin
Easton in a rubber match you two ain't
what two and two against him no one one
to one one and one and then Vandalia
yeah yeah Manley too I owe him a rubber
match but I would I would box vanilla
since he would watch that yeah
I'd watch that I'll Buxom what's the
chance of this happening I don't know I
haven't talked to him I don't know his
man I don't know who his manager is down
for would you be down for what if like a
Jake Paul started coming after you for
for me the Box yeah Jake Paul yeah I
don't lose 100 pounds yeah
man you know do you know how hard it's
going to be to lose 100 pounds I do you
said dig these legs up man yeah I think
your legs are the problem
I'm just it's like you're like man I
would but these thick legs
I didn't want to talk about the stomach
come on the stomach is not what's
weighing me down that much that's
probably like like 25 pounds the legs
are like they're like 75 pounds each but
but if there was like a catch weight
you'd be hoping
Jake be cool man
no way I could lose 100 pounds what what
about uh
yeah I wouldn't man with these legs man
these lazy okay I was going to blame it
on my penis but I couldn't get away with
that that don't weigh that much no well
you never know yeah
um so if there's I mean some boxing what
would you be open to would you what if
Dan off you a deal in the slap fight nah
[__] now
have you seen it I've seen it what do
you think this is crazy the [__] man I
honestly I thought it was really
entertaining that one guy had his face
all swollen up I was all on board yep so
that dude got that aneurysm and his face
was all messed up and then when the girl
when that then she you know she was
attractive girl but she was kind of
built when she smacked that girl so hard
she did a front flip and then woke up
and was like where am I I didn't sit
there like get back in there I'm like no
no I'll give it to it is like the shock
Factor like the entertainment value like
I can see it yeah but it can't be good
no no it's entertaining though I give it
that but no I'm not I'm not in it I'm
not see I wouldn't do bare knuckle or no
slap [__] I wouldn't do that [__] but if
Bear Knock if they paid me a couple
million I [__] somebody up I feel like
being a good pay a couple Mills I do
burn up here man bare Knuckles it's
Savage it's Savage I do it for a couple
of meal that's on the way because my
hands always I always [__] my hands up
break them yeah yeah they always get
[__] up my Knuckles and [__] do you
think that slap fight leaves gonna be
around for a while I don't think so me
neither I don't think so here's my
question like you if you're and I don't
hit on Dana for this but it's like
you're sad bro why are you why are you
entertaining this boy yeah I don't know
I don't know I was thinking that I'm
gonna be like Dana White tries out for
Arena Football League quarterback I'm
like why though yeah 400 bank I would
see Dana buying a knuckle League instead
of a slap League it that would make more
sense that makes more sense this one is
right you know he's a business dude I
just I don't understand it man right he
knows he knows I wish I knew business
like Dana I'll tell you that I mean
you're pretty good at it I mean you're
part of the the UFL yeah yeah those guys
they know business Harrison he knows
business yeah yeah yeah those guys they
their family are doing it right they
they doing something right how so with
like the insurance providers yeah you
can't you can't you can't beat that they
give him Fighters insurance and and life
insurance and a stake in the company so
you know who knows what's gonna happen
right they do it right they blow it big
just say one day they're worth half of
what the UFC worth in like 10 10 20
years think about all the guys that got
a percentage of that that'd probably be
millionaires let me know I mean my
question would the question for Harrison
is like so let's say let's say you
signed Bigfoot Silva right he got most
of his punishment outside of uh the UFL
so does he get compensate like life
insurance for what for here on out if
you gotta if you got a contract you it's
a multi-fight deal so you can't just do
one and done to get life insurance no no
you get yeah you have some dishes yeah
yeah no give me that life insurance let
me get the health insurance you gotta
it's like you get the health insurance
for your for your contract but the life
insurance I'm sure you know I'm I'm not
Harrison I didn't mean Max Harrison now
I need to access yeah
that would be my only
it's not even a pushback because you
know you guys are doing the Lord's work
giving guys health insurance life
insurance and all that other stuff in
the stock you know in the equity in the
company you just gotta
you know because you're around during
the Affliction days like when these
organizations come they dump all this
money into it and all the fighters like
they're doing it right and then they're
gone in a year yeah but see I think what
Affliction them though they was trying
to compete with the UFC they were they
were trying to go out there everyone
does yeah but these guys they're not
trying to compete with the UFC yeah
they're like um you know how right after
amateur when you first started Pro like
you know like they're like what king in
the cage levels but a little bit of cage
Elevate yeah but but I heard they're
paying more than what you saw it off
there though oh that's dope yeah so it's
like it's entry-level and then they're
going to keep growing and all we need is
for more fans to support and they'll
stick around like if if you if you
support a company that you really
believe in and the fans believe in and
they support it it'll be around but
they're not going right after the deal
so what exactly do you do for me I do a
lot of stuff for I do a lot of stuff for
them I'm going to get my own team well
if you're like I'm the nutritionist
do I look like a nutritionist
I'm not I'm the owner of a team and uh
sometimes
you know just help him promoting and you
know do your thing do my thing yeah
that's dope man yeah but I'm I'm really
excited about being the owner of the
team hell yeah and how many are on the
team uh 10 weight classes right
you tell me yes give me ten is it 10
weight class 10 weight classes
eight eight weight classes yeah
and so one from each weight class and
that's the team yeah I'm gonna have two
guys is it similar to IFL remember IFL
yeah I remember outfit it's similar
there but the scoring system is
different which is going to make it more
exciting let's go yeah but I'm gonna
have two guys per weight class case one
hurt or something you know they'll be
dropping into about whatever team wins
like team Rampage team may or whatever
yeah yeah you gotta have you got to have
so many points for the team to win you
know you better be careful doing like
Team USA team dagging staying that
dagger standing team oh yeah yeah yeah
they'd be tough huh yeah we ain't scared
of nobody though no I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go and recruit like the best guys
I can that can get get my hands on that
I can afford for my team that's the
thing you help a lot of guys out too
yeah especially at the gym you're out
there's some Savages yeah yeah I'm gonna
be going to a lot of other different
gyms and stuff too just recruiting my
team get like a good tight team you know
I'll tell you right now good luck
recruiting anyone to beat Frank man's
daughter I know just just don't
yeah she already said this super Savage
what weight class is she I just have to
get them away uh was she 220 no way
she's two no she's tiny now yeah yeah my
son I'm gonna get my son to fight it
like one 170 or 155. he's he says he can
make 155 but I haven't seen him yet how
big how big is he right now he's like
in shape 83 yeah he's not super Rip but
he's 55 be tough huh yeah 55 he said he
wants to go to 55 but I don't I don't
see him but I think he's too small for
170. how tall is he he's like um
511. but he's I don't think he's big
enough for 170 that's what they said
because the guys in 170 they cut down
for like 200 of them especially now some
big boys let's take a little break fam
from chatting with my boy Rampage
Jackson spring has sprung our friends at
manscape to have the best tools for some
spring cleaning they've already helped
you tidy up all the nooks and crannies
of your body's basement but this year
manscape can help you get the perfect
presentation on that beautiful face with
the new beard hedge Pro kit make sure
you look your best this spring by using
Code food truck to get twinks off and
free shipping at manscape.com it's time
to tame your Mane with the beard hedger
Pro kit the sun is peeking back out
which means you'll have to show your
face in the day all right so use the kit
to make sure your Scruff looks
award-winning whether you got glorious
beard flow or some smooth Sleek cheeks
the kid starts off with the beard hedger
a waterproof cordless trimmer that gives
you 20 hair cutting lengths what do you
want a Philly fade on your face you want
to do a flat top whatever you want we
got you covered it also comes with a
titanium coated t-blade all right it's
tough on the hair but smooth on your
face the beard header is a high-tech
piece of art and a travel size package
with long lasting battery Universal
charging and a strong motor it comes
with beer shampoo and conditioner they
got beard oil beard balm they got it all
for that fine ass beard of yours save 20
off and free shipping with the code food
truck at manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code food truck
at manscape.com focus on the face use
the beard hedger Pro kit for the
cleanest look in the game manscape it's
time for America's number one ready to
eat meal kit I'm talking about our
friends at Factor get nutritious Chef
prepared meals delivered straight to
your door leading you time and energy to
tackle everything in our to-do list you
don't need to be all up in the grocery
store waiting then come home chop it up
cook it up takes hours away from your
family from a busy day forget all that
look and feel your best in time for
warmer weather with the calorie smart
meals around 550 calories or less for
your thickies out there but you're too
busy to cook I'll say less with factors
skip the trip to the grocery store and
Skip The Chopping prepping cleaning up
two factors fresh never frozen meals are
ready to in just two freaking minutes so
all you have to do is heat and enjoy
Factor has delicious flavored packed
meals to help you live to the fullest
choose from keto vegan veggie Cali smart
Protein Plus which is your boys doing so
I'm psoriasis so I need to just meet
right now so that's cool at my age with
34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly option there's always something
new to try want to cut back gonna take
out cool get Factor not only is Factor
cheaper than takeout but meals already
faster than restaurant delivery it's
just two freaking minutes all right and
if you're eating vegan or veggie cool
man we got you covered because they can
provide that for you get fact or enjoy
clean eating without the hassle simply
choose your meals enjoy fresh flavored
packed meals delivered straight to your
door ready in just two minutes no prep
No Mess head to factormeals.com shop50
that's factormeels.com shop50
schab50 use the code shop 50 get 50 off
your first box that's code shop 50 at
factormeals.com shop50 to get 50 off
your first box now let's get back to
Rampage but then in a couple of years we
all going to be talking about AJ and the
key Savage Savage Little Broken Hearted
you didn't come over the UFC you gotta
be honest
yeah I think Bellator you know they got
they got they they got plans for them I
think um they're they're like um they're
paying them what he want to get paid and
I love Bellator work for Bellator love
Scott Coker absolutely love him and what
they do there I think he's doing the
Lord's work Scott's absolute best
promoter he's good to the fear to the
fighters Bellator love Bellator
I believe UFC USC alumni you know sorry
you pride and all your [__] you've done
but also the reason I won the UFC is
because
they're don't get wrong like the top
five guys in Bel tour they could jump
VOC compete top five all day yeah but
after that it gets dicey UFC's I mean
it's 155 145 170 one through 60. yeah 60
can [__] up number five it's a Savage
division so for AJ McKee just for his
legacy just for him to get more eyeballs
I just want to see him compete and have
that marketing machine behind him
because yeah we've got AJ on here great
kid such a [__] Talent yeah such a
talented man dude I went with him when
he found Japan and the Japanese fans
loved him instantly really loved them I
I was a bit jealous damn like that it
took him a while to like love me like
that he came out with the samurai suit
oh oh that tried his his walkout was
fine dude he's the only person that had
like a hundred thousand dollar walkouts
uniform yeah he's funny because he came
on my show right before he came World
Champ and uh he was like yeah man I just
want to win and then uh I have a GT2 on
that support she's like yeah I'm gonna
take the money I'm gonna buy that I'm
like oh no no don't waste all your money
on a car yeah yeah gradually get there
yeah because he's a Gearhead too he
loves cars yeah he loves cars yeah I
don't I don't know if this is his dad
try to keep some grounded but I I see I
see like him and his dad talk I think
his dad do the same thing I do sometimes
I ain't gonna you're gonna learn the
hard way yeah yeah he's such a talent
though yeah he's probably the most
talented dude him or the uh the was it
the I think he's at middleweight they're
champ there those two could come to UFC
top three right now I'm gonna tell you
they uh uh they got another kid in that
in the gym on Joey Davis when he when he
get inside oh Joe yeah yeah have you
seen Jay Davis Joey Davis wait till you
see him wait till you get his head on
straight really they got a few guys like
that yeah yeah just some Savages yeah
now this won't air before
um the the fighters on Saturday but you
got Fedor coming back yeah Fedor versus
Ryan Bader yeah that's how you feel
about fate or still doing the damn thing
what they said this is fatal's last
fight and um you know fatal has been my
favorite fighter for a long time
you know I guess we're about the same
age I understand why he's retired I hope
he wins his last his retirement fight me
too yeah but against Ryan better that'd
be a tough fight to me when guys like at
your level when you're like these
Legends it's like I don't get like in
faders fatal I'm sure you want to fight
Ryan Bader because he won the title but
they should be doing like these Legacy
fights where they're gonna fight with
their favor like you have to send off
cool like do you see what they do to
like Dominic Cruz against Cheeto Vera or
Frankie Edgar versus that Gutierrez kid
it's like why are you giving these young
lines yeah it should have been Frankie
versus Dom right they give them these
legendary fights I don't understand that
see that's if I if I if I fight in the
MMA again that's the only thing I want
to do like if Android Sylvan you would
make two legends going at it you know
something like that me and vandala in
the boxing match you said that you would
buy that right now yeah I'm a
degenerative I want you you know I was
slap Fight League man you watch that
[__] real I watched it once and my girl
couldn't stop laughing she couldn't
believe it's real and I go I can't
either and then once that dude's face I
[__] up I was like oh now I'm sad yeah
and then you find out how much they make
you're like holy [__] what he won though
did he though he can't make anybody
winning you know but he came back in one
though I mean I guess yeah the other guy
gave up or something hey dude here's two
G's and your face is [__] up for life
no no how much they get paid though two
and two
two and two
and then someone wrote that because they
went after a UFC fight and he posts he's
like slap Fight League reached out to me
they went off for me two and two and
then someone uh in the comments lit up
Dana was like man what are you doing two
and two [__] this and Daniel's like
educate yourself he's like two and two
that's what the UFC started back in the
day I'm like yeah [__] in 93. yeah 23
2-2 these boys can go work at Starbucks
right so [__] gas is high price
everything went up rent is up two months
two and two you're not eating an egg
omelette every day how much eggs are
these days hell no
damn man that's sad yeah two and two
will bum you out when I heard that my
god dog and then those rash guards like
their normal rascars you got kind of
guts too it ain't a sport if you have
their shirt out all the time oh yeah I
saw um it was an ex-ufc fighter they
went and knocked somebody outside it on
the clip today what UFC fight I can't
remember his name bro I can't remember
you see the one MMA fighter with sugar
in his tank and he slapped him was like
I was like oh no and then the dude was
like that's it
I thought it was unfair at the MMA
fighter came and slapped some regular
guy some guy but it's slapping though
right but he knocked him out the first
time dude you see Bigfoot Silas like he
showed a picture of his hand he's like I
I'm down to the slap fight Link who in
the [__] is gonna sign up to compete
against Bigfoot silver is he in already
he said he's down to do it now because
you know his chin God bless him I love
him as long as he gets to go first he'll
go undefeated for 10 years but if he if
somebody else gets start with his chance
it could be a problem
no he's been knocked out a bunch oh damn
yeah it's a bomber what a ways to be
that big and just get a chance his hands
and big dick beaters wow
he's a problem Doug
well let me feed you guys we don't you
don't got a fight coming up there's no
reason to cardio oh yeah I do I do I do
cardinals I do cardio I train I'm
working out five days a week now are you
lifting really hard and doing yeah you
got bigger from Saturday but you got
like thicker from when you get companion
yeah I'm lift I'm lifting and doing
cardio but let me feed you let's both
get thicker let's do this
foreign
[Music]
first of all appreciate you doing this
thank you for having
me I hope you got two thick ones here
today yeah right mainly in the legs
for steam all legs here what uh what's
your most popular uh items our most
popular is the cowboy 3.0 Burger
um it's gonna be right in the center oh
I see it
um 3.0 says three meats we have a double
b Patty Pepper Jack cheddar cheese
pulled pork bacon coleslaw pickle onion
rings and barbecue sauce interesting
um second would be the vegan navo Stacks
it's double Patty American cheese bacon
avocado
cup lettuce tomato pickles our Wicked
sauce which is a Chipotle meal and then
we add an over easy egg to that oh
interesting yeah you know what you want
yeah the scene see that bacon that bacon
they're making the Avo stack yeah I'm
thinking about that that one's my
favorite
yeah
I didn't like that sandwich I was like
yeah I might get it yeah
um the bulgogi snack is another one of
my favorites as well it's very different
you said you got a pukaki sandwich
see I almost want to get the Nashville
chicken International fries because I'm
from Tennessee but I ain't but I'm not
from Nashville though still though I'm
at your state but what kind of what's
what's the name I'll eat Rocky Mountain
Oysters no you do I mean Colorado that's
like that's like sheep balls oh my gosh
that's gross tastes like chicken I don't
know if you've never had chicken that's
what they say no okay I know I'm gonna
order I'm gonna order one of those yeah
yeah I'll I'll do an order of the Wicked
Wings
all right you know I take that that
sandwich again yeah that bacon but can I
get there with no tomatoes yeah
uh and I'll do the uh the wicked stack
can I get one of these grape drinks is
that great
yeah oh you knew I want that purple
stuff yeah the purple stuff you knew a
black guy was coming today didn't you
yeah there's only one of them hell y'all
laughing at there's one of them
you got any more purple stuff y'all nope
I think that's it
all right thank you so much
thank you y'all take food stamps
you know what I got you oh you got I got
you oh thanks I got them all right
but now I'm on my way
stayed up every single night and hustled
every day
[Music]
all right my man those fries look
intense and that home girl suggested
those yeah it's about to go all of them
yeah
why you keep talking about my legs these
legs are dope man what you talking about
they all muscle but look just a little
bit mainly mussels mainly muscles yeah
all right get your hands up to make the
stallion legs
Hercules all right I had to get the
fries because they Nashville you know
yeah I mean
I guess so naturally because they got
hot sauce on them you want to say grace
before you eat uh we can we've never
done it we can
I respect all religions around that
respect all religions I don't see no
french fries oh okay this this is they
hide them under the chicken tenders
let's take a little break from chatting
with the one then the only the original
out Rampage Jackson this episode of food
truck is brought to you by on it listen
I'm a busy dude that's by Design I have
psoriasis so I need to cut back a little
but I'm never gonna stop I like to have
a lot of my plate and not it helps me
maintain focus in order to function and
stay right in the zone all right my
favorite part about Alpha Brain and when
I take this the Black Label it promotes
attention focus Alpha Brain helps to
support cognitive functions include
memory mental speed and focus look how
fast I'm talking this South bring black
your boys always either podcasting or
doing stand up and trust me I need all
the mental speed I can get I need that
turbo boost of this brain I got all
right CT is coming so enjoy the next
three years otherwise it's gonna be too
late all right what are the benefits to
Alpha Brain yes oh man eight-dimental
processing caffeine free so you don't
get the Jitters helps with the flow
State promotes Focus supports Memory
Alpha Brain can help you all right
remember names places addresses phone
numbers when's last time you knew your
mom's address or phone number or your
lady friends or guys friends folks on
complex tasks think more clearly under
stress react more quickly check check
all right you want to be like Jeff Bezos
do you or not then don't take it fine
Anna also offers fitness equipment like
kettlebell steel Club maces sandbags
yoga mats need better nutrition because
you're getting thick already all right
on it has all that they got protein
powders Warrior bars protein bars we got
it all streaming Fitness for your thick
self all right and they're going to help
you achieve your fitness goals not too
late I know January is supposed to start
maybe you're just getting on the
treadmill now it's not too late all
right go to audit.com receive 10 off
everything I've listed including Alpha
Brain Black also without for brain
if you don't love it you get your money
back keep the product no return
necessary get your money back that's all
confident they are in Alpha Brain
they've sold over a million freaking
bottles get you some on it.com shop
receive temperature off the entire site
you're welcome
this episode of fruit truck Diaries is
brought this last one I promised this
episode of food truck dies is brought to
you by my friends at happy hippo it's
the best crater on the freaking planet
listen you ever just stare at a hippo
and think why are they so freaking happy
and they come up with all these cool
gadgets and ideas how can I be more like
a hippo well I'm here to let you in on a
little secret they're using happy hippo
that's right
happyhippo.com the best Kratom on the
planet you can't just trust any old
Kratom company out there we have no idea
what to put in those bottles don't do it
you can only trust one and that's
happyhippo.com it's the best Focus the
best warm feeling you happy feeling your
overall mood changes I just create them
every single day for every single thing
that I do and I only use one company
it's my Limitless pill it's
happyhippo.com you can save 20 off by
going to happyhippo.com promo code is
thick 23 that's thick with three C's and
be like the hippos get happy come up
with cool ideas create cool gadgets just
like all the hippos do it's happy
hippo.com promo code thick23 you're
welcome now let's get back to the
program uh but you're in town obviously
I mean you live not too far away yeah I
live in Orange County yeah man so but
are you excited about uh Bellator doing
kind of honoring the legends of the game
I mean look at the list you're with I
mean you know this you're freaking
Legend I don't have to you know jerk
your leg off here yeah I don't have to
jerk them thick legs off but you know
it's a u-rank tour Royce Gracie Coleman
Chael sonen just the the grand old
Legends how do you feel about it
I love all those guys but I'm not
excited to see
um Randy Couture I can't stand that
[__]
really yeah I don't even want to be in
the same ring why not random two is a
[__] [__] man what happened
uh back in back in the day when I was
championing stuff
in the UFC in the UFC I started being
sponsored by him remember he had that
extreme Couture yeah I do yeah and uh I
had like the number one selling shirt
the woods with the chains and stuff like
that Affliction screen Couture so I'm it
was it was like his company too right it
was in Couture with Affliction they
sponsored me I'm wearing a t-shirt
making random Couture a shitload of
money I made pretty good money too but
uh when I when I was fighting he would
do interviews and picked up my opponents
over me that's not cool it's like
monster doing an interview right before
you know say I fight and said oh another
guy yeah I don't know you know given
what would you call it giving their
predictions yeah but why would he do
that he did it he did it three times he
did it with with
um
Rashad Evans I'm like okay yeah I could
I could lose the result and I ended up
losing to Rashad he did it with um
leoto Machida that I'm a cheetah I said
yeah that's a tough fight okay yeah he
was just doing normal yeah and then he
did it against Matt Hamill that's when I
was like man okay that's where he goes
yeah that's one that's why I got it then
he's just a hater the other two yeah
fear
s Matt Hamill though I can see where
he's yeah he's throwing some shades I
see if that was unprofessional the other
two but I can yeah but then have you
ever talked to him about it [__] no I
just saw it because I just that just
made you mad it made me mad because you
know we all looked up to rent it you
know hell yeah yeah I like Randy yeah
he's never done anything to me though I
used to like Randy I feel you hold some
grudges like you still you want to fight
scoon over yeah how you pronounce his
name uh Daryl schoonover is it
schoonover schoonover
schoonover oh you want to fight him yeah
you're down to fight Marvin Eastman back
in the day yeah you don't like uh you
don't like uh
Randy Couture I'll fight Randy too old
hell yeah I'll fight his old ass he he
wanted to fight me before he returned I
know because he wanted to come train
with me and I know Randy Couture he
likes to come train with you before he
fights you do you think they're gonna uh
just step are people aware that you guys
have this beef now do you think there's
beef or do you think it's just beef on
Rampages this is beef on my side uh-huh
because um
he talks [__] about me fighting leoto
and he was saying like how he how he
would have beat the Yoda better than me
it's like I've been in my decision and
even when I got his tooth knocked out
and I I kept quiet I didn't say nobody
laughed though kicked him right now
right in the mouth lost his tooth
actually helped him train for that fight
the night before who you have trained
Randy that's your boy he hit me in the
face no we had the same coach Neil Mount
Nelson I was walking I was just seeing
my parents for the UC UFC Toronto and he
was like where you going Mike
something go do something really cool my
hotel room say no no you come to the
train you're coming to train with uh
Randy he needs help I was like oh man I
go train I thought it'd just be like
there for like one round nah five rounds
me home minutes getting beat up by Randy
Couture hit me right in the face and
that's the mitt man you the wrong spawn
partner trying to partner for him he's a
softball I don't know karate right I
don't drink pears
yeah I I remember yeah Leo though he's
great that was that was one of the
hardest training camps I ever had bro I
had to bring in some karate guys and I
brought in like a karate instructor from
the UK
he was in one of those movies Legos
throwing their gentleman or something oh
really he's one of the guys in that
movie but he was like a Big Time karate
guy is Sean Connery it wasn't Sean
Connery he was another old guy I don't
know I can't remember his name Terry
something maybe I can't remember his
name but he's a badass he's badass but
he brought in something he brought in
some guys he got mad when I was kicking
the karate guy's ass but because he
thought they were like because that's
his background that was his background
so I was like man why are you even
trading me but that's everyone like
anyone who fights like Wonder Boy like
people don't realize like when you sign
up for that fight against the other or
like a Wonder Boy you have to bring in
that karate style you have to you have
to otherwise you you can't lift the hell
up yeah you're not gonna be prepared for
people forget how [__] good the other
Machida was in this Heyday man he was
good as [__] nicest guy ever too yeah
he's a great dude you think he really
drink piss though I mean there's video
of it I don't think he does anymore
thing he does anymore this video it and
it kind of makes sense you know he was
like I take all these vitamins and they
go through your you know your liver so
you don't want to miss out on the
vitamins like just take more vitamins I
was thinking that buy some more vitamins
yeah don't recycle vitamins the vitamins
you know more vitamins I don't drink
piss but I get it I get the idea behind
it but not for me
um yeah I feel like you hold on to
grudges yeah I do I guess because I
heard you on adam22 saying that uh Rogan
didn't have you on because some deal
wrote them was criticizing checking
light kicks yeah but I don't got nothing
against Roger though oh I'm not mad at
Rogan
Roman's not mad at you are you
guaranteed guarantee I'm gonna give you
the biggest hug yeah I'm not mad at
Rogan but I you know he came up he just
asked me have I ever been on Rogan and I
told him no I never been like he never
asked me to be on but you assumed it's
because you got an issue because he was
criticizing your leg kicks like back in
the day right yeah I think I said that's
probably like why he never asked me on
because we had we had some work we we
talked we talked about it backstage at
the UFC though
last for my song and he was saying you
gotta check those light kicks
I I I went off on him though oh did you
I went off on him because bro since
social media like the fans like they
come right to you and they come to you
in your DMs especially whatever what
Rogan says he's so powerful so if Rogan
says uh whatever Rampage has bad head
movement
all the only comes like because they
can't think for themselves you have bad
head movements like God damn right so
that after a while but he he's not doing
that he's doing not helping yeah if you
check latex I think it's gonna work
better yeah now um I I I'm more along
the lines of your thinking too
especially when I was fighting I was in
the biggest leg kicker I would check the
kicks I'd rather eat a kick and then
land this right hand you know get Wi-Fi
Gonzaga Crow cop those guys that kick
cool kick me yeah cause that ain't gonna
end the fight this is all right so I'll
take your leg kicks because this that
won't end the fight this well yeah
yeah 15 minutes yeah it's a fun one
he was a big [__] oh man it was
Harry too for real I remember they're
doing the piss test I saw his piss it
was just Brown I was like damn you
dehydrated or you're on top
how you fought somebody was really
smelly though
pro cop smelled like Croatian hummus for
real awful
wow that was like a tactic of this yeah
I think that's that I thought two people
that was real smelly I think it has to
be a who was it one was um that my first
K1 fight the um french guy
um Cyril ability
and then that guy that guy smelled like
at least two weeks that makes sense and
um and um Matt Linden not all yeah Matt
linland just looks just smelly yeah I
heard like it like it look his knee
brace looks like it stinks bro bro I
heard when he take a shower he just
getting there and spin around twice and
good
hell yeah he's a tough fight but you
could tell he's smelly I I could call
that a mile away there's some dudes just
look smelly
well tell your boy Joe I ain't mad at
him I guarantee he loves you he's not
even thinking about it you know what I'm
saying but you were right I'm along the
lines with you like especially back then
now it's a little different if you're
fighting a guy who's a straight up like
Savage light kicker yeah the game's
changed but when you and I were fighting
it just like it's like when the way
Gonzaga kick or Co-op would kick it
wasn't like it was if it was a heck it
could be in trouble those light kicks
I'll eat those Atlanta right handles
yeah and we train for that yeah but I
don't think and their line of thinking
they're they're not they don't realize
that like that's part of the game plan
yeah we know they kick we know how to
deal with it but for Joe he's probably
thinking oh Rampage doesn't work on leg
kick so you know yeah he doesn't realize
he said I wasn't kicking people and um
so I almost listened to Joe when I
fought um Matt Hamill almost got taken
down because I was like let me kick
because I'm tired yeah but whenever you
see me fighting
and I had my leg my ankle taped yeah
I was planning to kick oh that makes
sense but to your point too you didn't
want to get taken down I didn't want to
get taken down because people because
when people took me down they just laid
on top of me and I hated that yes when
you throw a cake remember you're on one
leg Yeah so for someone who grapple they
want you to Camp they want you to get
one leg Yeah
and they don't go they don't go for the
ground a pound or the submission of me
they just lay there and just hold you
tight make sure you don't get back up
yeah and I hate that I get it dude
it makes more boring fight so you're
looking forward to this Legends kind of
thing but you just don't want to see
around the guitar I don't want to see
Randy tour
I bet you guys squash the beef
you'll run into each other and be like
old times
I'm cordial but you're cool with
everyone yeah yeah I'm cordless I see
I'm recording but he know I don't like
him I'm here in trombone hey remember in
2012 when you picked Matt Hamill man
never forget that
do I sound like a um like a um
what do I sound like a grumpy old man
yeah no because I think it makes it who
you are too like you don't forget those
things you know you make it personal and
I think in the fighting that helped you
out I think it's time to let it go yeah
if he wasn't my sponsor I wouldn't I
wouldn't give two shits
but yeah you feel like you're part of
the team kind of stuff yeah I bet you
talk to me is like oh sorry man I was
just doing
yeah it's a black and white thing you
know like a numbers thing I thought Matt
Hamill's gonna beat you yeah maybe oh
how yeah agree
um I got some gifts for you though man
first of all how's your food man it's
good man it's really good does it take
to bring you back to the Nashville
I got it because I never I never had
fries like this in Nashville yeah they
just called Nashville fries in Nashville
you're not gonna find those fries oh
they they're supposed to advertisement I
thought when I go to Nashville
they got you I wanted to say something I
don't want to break through something
well now you have a grudge against that
poor lady
well I wanted to mail this to you but
you won the award for last year
you got me something oh yeah I get you a
few things it's like Christmas right now
oh God damn something so you got the
thick white this is a what we're getting
for the drunkest
[__] I was drunk last night
tiger thick this [__] that changed all
you
look at that I mean that was built for
Rampage
this is dope it's gonna be tough to beat
that too this coming year I mean could
you a jelly roll might beat you because
that oh yeah that's a drink but the way
the way he sounds sounds like he has a
stronger tolerance of me yeah yeah you
don't he doesn't look hammered but he's
fun time so you got that you got your
thick boy award for uh drunkest Mother
after of the year and then these are
from my boys at suplex Philly I always
uh I partner up with him because I'm a
sneak ahead I always give a shoot to the
fighters and then I picked a shoe
because I feel like it resembles the
fighter has to you know we give sugar
Shawn the the dope like tie-dye Jordan J
Balvin Jordans these are for you I'm
jealous I'm jealous of these
these are yours oh thanks bad boys I
wasn't I wasn't expecting yeah I guess
anything I'm just gonna bring you down
here and feed your Nashville fries oh
yeah these [__] are lit the
Supreme Club Jordan Fives the Supreme
yeah dog hard to find these are hard to
find yes I'm trying to rob me for these
[__] because you know I I be
going to some like I wouldn't wear those
in like uh you know you could wear those
around uh Randy Couture at the thing oh
okay Randy you'd be fighting around
there I'd be fine it's old ass better
not try to rob me he might for those
he's in the military but those desert
camo son yeah I don't have those I'm
jealous
they should done collab with you on that
dude that was very that was very
thoughtfully just like look at that yeah
they're filthy Supreme clap too not easy
to get my man oh man is it just for you
no you're the man and you're gonna be
back March 4th in the companion watching
Jon Jones fight yeah man you're the best
do I get shoes that time too good I mean
you can you can just every time I see I
use some dope shoes they won't be as
good as those
but uh yeah we love you man appreciate
you doing the show enjoy dude take it in
this weekend
give me some advice should I should I
just like hug hug Randy it's gonna do
better for you man that resentment stuff
there's no need for it over a t-shirt
who gives a [__] any Pig get you okay
you still won you know you're still
winning well I lost one of the times he
picked against me but against uh Rashad
yeah he's running the other two yeah so
you still won right like who cares man
at this age too do it for me all right
that's good he's the best brother all
right enjoy the kicks all right thanks
man Rampage Jackson everybody